top story of the night back from her
exclusive interview with the president
today she is Fox and Friends co-host
Ainsley her how are you good to see you
big interview there's a lot there let's
first start to the news from yesterday
he talked a lot about Michael Cohen we
just heard part of it Paul Manafort tell
us what he's sitting well so when we sat
down with him my questions were Michael
Cohen story changed originally he said
that I paid off women the president
didn't know about it then all of a
sudden his story changes and then he's
also pleading guilty to eight different
counts so do we believe him that was the
question this morning you know this is a
guy that's lied tax returns fraud all
this and now he's changing his story
about the president so when I sat down
with the president I said my number one
question that I wanted to ask him is
what happened did you know did he pay
off these women did you know about it
and he said I didn't at first and now I
know about it and he said well if it
wasn't illegal because we've had several
attorneys that have been on they were
our morning show saying it's not illegal
to do this so if it's not illegal then
how did he get a plea bargain how did he
get he was facing 65 years behind prison
behind bars in prison how did he go from
65 years possibly max to 3 to 5 years if
it wasn't illegal why are they using
that he said because if there is
something negative that they can say
about me they will use that and they
will lessen their sentence that that
extreme just because they hate me keep
in mind this was the Muller
investigation Muller investigation was
was looking into manna for its past was
looking into Cohen's past and that led
them to all of these tax fraud it has
nothing to do with Russia see more mad
at Michael because of the tape
absolutely say Paul Manafort because I
noticed in his comments yesterday men
should mana for but not Michael he
mentioned pardoning mana Ford and then
you have Michael Cohen's attorney in
pardoning he did he did and said that he
would consider that he feels I think he
feels so I think he feels bad for
Manafort they were friends he didn't
work for him for very long work for him
for basically a hundred days the
president didn't know about all of this
tax stuff of course he wouldn't
and he did say he said keep in mind he
worked for Reagan for a long time work
for a long time was talking about that
yeah it's just because he's associated
with me and they hate me so much did you
what I'm pointing out I believe and I've
talked about this for a long time is
that there are these forces against the
president I talked about five of them I
also believe what the Democrats agenda
that telegraphing it 76 days from now
there's gonna be an election I believe
and I've been saying on the air that
they would want to impeach him did any
of with all the hysteria in the media
did that come up at all it did I asked
him that question I said if the
Democrats win the midterms their agenda
is gonna be doing peach because there's
no rush of collusion at least so far so
what's the next step if they hate you so
much what are they gonna do and he
agreed that impeachment they're gonna
try to impeach and he says he basically
expects that you know there's so many
key players here and there is such a
double standard cuz we have we know a
lot we know Hillary obstruction we know
that she paid for Russian propaganda to
influence the American people which is
kind of cheating because it was never
verified or corroborated these were lies
that she paid for funneled money which
is another issue we just pointed out but
then you've got you know you got the
FISA warrant abuse nobody seems nobody's
getting indicted in those cases a lot of
this goes back to Jeff Sessions yeah did
he talk about either Jeff or rod or Moe
I can't tell you what he said about that
because I did ask him and I got a say
for the morning show did ask him I said
are you gonna fire Jeff Sessions they're
rumors you're gonna fire him they're
rumors you're gonna fire Rosenstein and
you know what are you thinking and I'm
not going to-- you got to watch the
morning show because i can't give it all
away he did say that it's such a double
standard beyond a double standard what
happened with hillary clinton how she
got off what happened that's gonna break
news what do you said about sessions of
Rosenstein absolutely absolutely Wow
what else can you tell us there was so
much more we asked him about Molly
Tibbets and ice how he's doubled down
you know he's gotten so many people are
saying abolish ice abolish ice but he
doubles down he brings ice to the White
House and honors them there was a lot of
news here that people want to see in the
I was really I will say there was so
much breaking news yesterday and there
was so much negative news hats off to
him for sitting down with me today I
think that was very brave because we
learned to journalism school if someone
sets a narrative you've got to defend
yourself
Clady thank you for sharing your
interview we appreciate it thank you
morning 6:00 tonight